in this lecture i want to get into the
various ways that the judiciary
is part of the political processes in
the united states
i'm going to start by talking about the
very political process
of when a president appoints a supreme
court justice
then we'll dive into some political
effects of the court's actions
the supreme court plays a role in policy
making through its decisions and
precedents
and the public organized interests and
parties have a variety of means to try
to affect the court's rulings
i'll talk about how that works and then
i want to take a short walk through
history
to gain some perspective on how the
court's role in politics and government
has changed over time by the end i think
you'll have a good sense of how this
mysterious institution works and how it
affects the basic rights that americans
enjoy
the first topic i want to mention in
this lecture is how
justices get onto the supreme court
supreme court justices are appointed by
the president
and subject to approval by the senate
a justice must receive a majority vote
in the senate to be approved
and seated on the court usually
the senate does not rigorously
investigate the appointee
historically most supreme court nominees
have been
relatively non-controversial and have
been approved by wide majorities in the
senate
however this tradition or norm has begun
to break down in the last 10 years or so
the primary reason this norm has changed
is due to partisan polarization
in the u.s senate we'll cover the topic
of polarization in more detail
in another lecture but let me say a bit
more about it
here to make a point about supreme court
appointments
if we think of senators as having a
single position on a one-dimensional
left-right
ideological scale where left is liberal
and right is conservative then in the
u.s senate
the median democratic senator has moved
to the left
and the median republican senator has
moved ideologically to the right
such that the gap between the two
parties
has been growing importantly
republicans have moved more than
democrats have
in other words when political scientists
look at the votes and positions that
senators take
we see that republicans in the senate
have moved more to the right
than democrats have to the left
this polarization of the senate has
had a profound effect on the politics of
supreme court appointments
for example prior to 2017
supreme court nominees were subject to a
filibuster in the senate
this meant that a super majority of
senators or 60 of them
would need to support the motion to take
a vote on a nominee's appointment
in the past this meant that supreme
court nominees would typically need
bipartisan support to get through the
senate
and this requirement gave pres
presidents an incentive to nominate
justices
that would be palatable to some
bipartisan
supermajority of senators
however in 2017 republicans in the
senate changed the rules
to eliminate filibusters on supreme
court nominees
and president donald trump's nominee
neil gorsuch
was approved on a 54-45
vote the vote to confirm another
even more controversial nominee to the
court was even closer
in 2018 president trump's pick for the
supreme court
brett kavanaugh was confirmed on a 50-48
vote a side note here
the vote to confirm justice kavanaugh
would have been
51-49 but two senators
use a custom known as pairing their
votes
senator steve daines of montana had
intended to vote yes
but he did not attend the vote in order
to be at his daughter's wedding
out of courtesy to her colleague senator
lisa murkowski of alaska
had intended to vote no but instead she
voted present
so that the two votes would cancel each
other out and not
affect the outcome both senators are
republicans
as a second aside i should note that
republicans
changed this rule in 2017 as
part of a retributive action against
democrats
who also changed the rules in 2013
allowing federal court nominees to be
approved
without being subject to a filibuster
both parties have played a hand in
changing the norms of the senate
in ways that exacerbate the partisan
acrimony
that has gripped the chamber forcing it
into a fair amount of dysfunction
but i digress i'll talk more about that
another time
it's important to note that presidents
tend to take very seriously their
responsibility in nominating supreme
court justices
in part because justices serve with
lifetime
tenure once appointed to the supreme
court
it's your job until you retire or expire
in this sense supreme court justices
outlast
presidents and so presidents see their
appointments
as a way to establish a legacy that
effectively
continues their presidency of course
it can be difficult for presidents to
anticipate how
justices will rule during their time on
the court
and sometimes they've guessed wrong
there are four major categories of
influences on the supreme court
taking the institutional perspective
that i talked about in the previous
lecture
it should be clear that the president
has an obvious
direct influence on the court in virtue
of the ability to nominate justices
members of the supreme court
tend to be highly respected and
accomplished
jurists by one point of view the
justices of the supreme court
are members of the country's smallest
and most exclusive club
where the qualifications for membership
are almost
unbelievably high the application
of justice is fabled to be blind
meaning that judges and justices are
supposed to apply
the rule of law without regard to any
biases
that might influence their decision
making but
justices are people too and all people
have biases and
personal experiences that color their
world world views
although partisanship is not an explicit
component of the way justices identify
themselves or decide cases
most justices have ideological leanings
that are apparent in their legal
writings and former cases they have
decided
presidents will often attempt to learn
about these traits
among a small set of highly qualified
jurists
and select ones that are most similar to
their own
in today's highly polarized political
environment
ideologies and worldviews are
increasingly associated with
partisanship
i'll talk more about why that is in
another lecture but for now
we can simply acknowledge that jurists
have
biases that influence their decision
making
and these can inform us about how
partisanship
and potentially polarization exists on
the supreme court
another major influence on the supreme
court comes from congress
this happens most directly through the
senate confirmation process that i
talked about in the previous lecture and
while that process has become more
politically charged in the last decade
or so
the act of confirming a judicial nominee
is one of the more
captivating things to observe congress
also has the authority to define court
jurisdictions
through though this does not happen very
often
organized interests comprise a third
influence on the court
sometimes when a case is being appealed
to the supreme court
or when a case is already on the court's
docket
organized groups attempt to sway the
court's decision
to hear a case or affect how the court
might decide a particular case
these groups have a formal means of
communicating their positions to the
court
through a process known as amicus curai
which is latin for friend of the court
quite literally an ally of a party in a
particular
case can opt to submit an amicus brief
that presents arguments evidence or
reasoning in support of or against a
particular claim
filing an amicus brief has become a
common practice in the last several
decades
for example in 1954 when the supreme
court heard the landmark
case of brown versus board of education
and ordered the racial desegregation of
schools
there were only six amicus briefs filed
about 20 years later the case that
legalized abortion and its restrictions
roe vs wade had 23 amicus briefs
when the supreme court heard obergefell
versus hodges in 2015
the case that provided legal protections
for same-sex marriage
there were 149 total amicus briefs
77 that supported the petitioner
obergefell
and 67 that supported the respondent
hodges
and five that were neutral
a final influence on the court that i
want to mention is
public opinion scholars have closely
examined the relationship between the
supreme court
and public opinion and found the two to
be correlated
however scholars are not fully in
agreement about
why the correlation exists and if there
is a causal relationship
about which direction it might go
to the extent that court decisions and
public opinion
are associated with one another does the
court follow public opinion
or does it help to set public opinion
scholars have shown
that political institutions including
the supreme court
are dynamically responsive to public
mood
and perceived attitudes and one may
consider this
a desirable characteristic for a
democracy
for instance in 2009 a study showed that
as public support for the supreme court
declined
the court struck down fewer federal laws
a reason for this could be that the
court senses a need to stay
in the good graces of the public and
avoid
being overly contrarian as a way to
maintain its legitimacy on the other
hand
it could also be that the court being
made of human beings living in society
is simply reflective of where the public
is
the political scientist james stimson at
university of north carolina at chapel
hill
has studied public mood for many decades
in 2019 he showed that over the past
four years there has been a sharp uptick
in the public mood
towards more liberal policies in fact
the general public has a greater
appetite for liberal policies now
than it has had at any time in the past
68 years
the general public trend towards
liberalism
does not seem to track all that well
with the current lien of the court
but as we'll see the court is a small
and
peculiar body made up of a specific type
of political appointee
there are two broad theories that
describe the court's relationship with
the general public
we can think of these as judicial
activism and judicial restraint
under the theory of judicial activism
courts take an expansive
view of judicial power suggesting that
judges and justices
make decisions that have strong lasting
and meaningful effects on life for the
united states
for much of the latter half of the 20th
century
judicial activism was associated with
ideological
liberalism largely because of the strong
role that
courts played in establishing and
protecting civil liberties
through the u.s civil rights movement
and
this trend continued with follow-up
movements that focused on
various forms of social justice such as
environmentalism
and women's rights
on the other hand the theory of judicial
restraint suggests
that courts should primarily respect
existing precedents
and avoid taking monumental action this
theory suggests
that courts should not make decisions as
if they are policy makers
and that policy formation is best left
to legislative bodies
through the latter half of the 20th
century the theory of judicial restraint
was most closely associated with
ideological conservatism
largely because late 20th century
conservatism
was nominally focused around traditional
ideas
and protecting the status quo the theory
of judicial restraint
is consistent with a strict
constructionist perspective
meaning that judges should only look to
the words as they are
written in the constitution and apply
their meaning
today these theories are becoming less
useful
in helping us to discern why the court
does what it does
whether a ruling is activist or
restrictive is less
correlated with ideology than it used to
be today
ideology is a better framework to
explain court decisions
however understanding the ideology of
justices
isn't perfectly predictive either let me
talk a bit about what we know about that
during the civil rights era from about
the 1950s to the 1980s
the supreme court played an active and
critical role
in advancing civil rights and civil
liberties for a number of
sub-populations
in the u.s many have argued that without
the influence of several
key supreme court decisions the civil
rights movement itself
would not have been as successful as it
was
but beginning in 1980 things began to
change
america had 12 years of ideologically
conservative presidents
with ronald reagan and george h.w bush
and together they made six appointments
to the supreme court
it was during this era that a clear
ideological pattern
began to emerge on the nine-member court
where a block of four conservative
justices voted together
a block of four liberal justices voted
together
and a swing justice was pivotal in many
cases
for example in the court's 2000
term justice william rehnquist a nixon
appointee
who was elevated to chief justice by
reagan
and conservative clarence thomas a bush
appointee
voted together in 99 of all cases in
fact
rehnquist thomas antonin scalia
and anthony kennedy often voted together
as a block
around the turn of the century to boot
the court's most
liberal justices stephen breyer
ruth bader ginsburg david suter and john
paul stevens
also generally voted together for many
years
justice sandra day o'connor a moderate
conservative
appointed by ronald reagan in 1981 and
the first woman to serve on the supreme
court
she was the swing justice
in 2000 the court heard a critical case
bush versus gore that helped to settle
legal uncertainties and irregularities
arising from the presidential election
that year
in that case o'connor sided with the
conservatives in a 5-4
vote that handed the presidency to
george w bush
all told in that term about one-third of
cases
were decided by five to four votes
when justice o'connor retired in 2006
anthony kennedy became the new swing
justice
shifting the median vote of the court a
bit to the right
justice kennedy retired in 2018
and today's supreme court has a solid
block
of five conservatives and four liberals
looking at the court just prior to
kennedy's retirement
in its 2017 term there were many five to
four decisions
and they all favored the conservative
lien on the court
the court's 2018 term looked different
but perhaps not in the way you might
expect if
ideology explains everything looking at
the five to four decisions in the 2018
term half of those favored the
conservatives
and half favor the liberals generally
speaking
in fact the court set a record in its
2019
term for having the most variety in the
various blocks that formed over the
course of that term
so both liberals and conservatives on
the court
have defected from the traditional
alignments that we observed so
strongly at the end of the 20th century
this means that in recent years there
really is
no swing justice on the court at least
not in the way that o'connor and kennedy
played for so long
all told the majority of decisions that
the court
hands down now are falling in a
conservative direction
given the balance of ideology on the
court but
the justices that make up the
conservative majority
on any given case are not always the
block that one might expect
ideology is therefore a useful way
to understand the supreme court and its
decisions but
it's far from the most predictive at
least when looking at the current court
when thinking about the role of the
supreme court throughout u.s history and
its politics
i broadly think about three distinct
periods
the period from 1789 until the civil war
in the 1860s
then the period between the civil war
through world war ii
then the period after world war ii until
now
in that first period the major conflicts
that the supreme court got involved with
were
those involving federalism the court was
petitioned to hear many fewer cases back
then compared to today
but those it heard often dealt with
settling whether
states or national government had power
over something
for example the court considered cases
like mcculloch versus maryland
that directly dealt with federal power
over state power
all in all the court was not asked to
intervene in matters
very often during the first 70 years or
so of u.s history
and when it did it was on issues of
grand importance and scale
during this period the court generally
sided with the federal government
over state governments and many
historians
see this as an effort of institutional
preservation
in that era the persistence of the
united states as a viable government
was somewhat uncertain
the country was new and the powers
established for the government
were bold yet vulnerable as a key
institutional feature of the new
american experiment in democracy
the supreme court tended to decide
questions in favor of the side
that lent more legitimacy to the
authority of the federal government to
exist
for many of these early years john
marshall was the chief justice of the
court
when roger b tawney became chief justice
in 1836
the court shifted more toward states
rights
which exacerbated tensions that
contributed to the american civil war
from 1861 to 1865.
in addition in 1857 the tawny court
decided
dred scott versus sanford in which the
court sided with a slave owner
when a missouri slave tried to sue for
his freedom
the case galvanized support for slavery
lending it legitimacy
that directly contributed to the civil
war
during the second period from the middle
of the 1800s through world war
ii most of the conflicts that the court
was asked to resolve
had to do with government versus the
economy
both of which greatly expanded during
that period
the industrial revolution was a period
filled with great innovation and
technological advancements
in transportation communication
agriculture
electricity and more these developments
fundamentally changed the way most
people in america
experienced their everyday lives goods
people and services could move more
easily around the country
and the rapid expansion of tools and
technology
allowed many more people to share in an
expanding
prosperity during this period
america also experienced intense growth
in the population
driven by mass immigration and advances
in medical care
all of these changes significantly
increased demands on government
the physical space of the u.s also
greatly expanded
as the country achieved its so-called
manifest
destiny by acquiring all of the
continental land from ocean to ocean
over a great latitude people needed more
from government
during this time and governments at all
levels
rapidly grew to meet these needs when
disputes were brought
to the court they were often about
whether to prioritize
the expanse of industry or the
government's ability to regulate
industry
at the beginning part of this period
courts tended to side with
industry as society's elites strongly
favored the robust
economic expansion that was propelling
many people into positions of privilege
but as this went on it became
increasingly clear that not everyone was
benefiting from this expansion
in fact those who were benefiting in
many cases were doing so
at the expense of others particularly
when it came to workplace labor abuses
and harmful working conditions
by the beginning of the 20th century
calls to protect the disadvantaged had
become louder
and the court eventually began to swing
towards government's ability
to regulate the economy over industry's
right to grow
after world war ii the court entered a
critical period
of resolving disputes between
individuals and government
and it largely remains in this general
paradigm today
beginning with the court's early action
on landmark civil rights cases
like brown versus board of education and
civil liberties cases like
miranda versus arizona the court
intervened in critical questions in the
20th century
concerning the role of government and
establishing and protecting liberties
and equalities for individuals
it is no accident that the period of
history that included the greatest
expansion of government
was followed by a period in which courts
were asked
to settle disputes about the appropriate
roles of government
today the court is confronted with
disputes
related to abortion gun rights
immigration laws and access to health
care
despite being asked to hear many cases
today's court only takes on less than
one percent of those requests
this is primarily a workload constraint
because each supreme court case involves
dozens of filings
briefs multiple parties and often
complicated questions
the nine justices often go through many
negotiations and drafts on a single case
and despite having clerks and other
forms of assistance
it's difficult to imagine the court
increasing its workload
beyond its current capacity
every once in a while some politician or
activist gets interested in
making reforms to the supreme court
while
it is often considered the most revered
respected and widely approved of
america's
federal government institutions it's
also
the most mysterious the supreme court
has never allowed
cameras in its oral testimonies supreme
court
justices themselves are often quite
elusive
rarely making public appearances the
supreme court
does allow audio recordings during oral
testimony
but the overall lack of access and
minimalist media provide the supreme
court with a sort of
veil of secrecy some have suggested
that it's the distance that the court
maintains from the public
that helps to contribute to its sense of
authority legitimacy and reputation as
an
impartial arbiter however in modern
american politics where
it seems like everything is hyper
partisan and polarized
it's becoming increasingly difficult for
the supreme court
to maintain this distance and reputation
it may be worthwhile to remember that a
little less than a hundred years ago
there was a rather serious effort to
reform the supreme court
it was during the great depression and
frank president franklin delano
roosevelt
was interested increasing the role of
the federal government
in regulating the economy as a way of
lifting the united states into recovery
however the court was not cooperative at
first
between 1935 and 1937
roosevelt was met with steady resistance
as the supreme court denied and rejected
many of his attempts at government
expansion and economic regulation
in part due to his frustration roosevelt
began promoting the possibility of
expanding the court
to include not nine but 15 justices
one additional justice for every justice
currently older than 70 and a half
he suggested that by adding six
additional justices to the court
that he himself would select it would
tip the balance of power
in the court in his favor roosevelt's
proposal became known
as the court packing plan
there is no question that a president
manipulating the supreme
court in the way that roosevelt proposed
is
a rather dramatic violation of
democratic norms
as the only president in u.s history to
be elected four times to the presidency
roosevelt was not particularly loyal to
the norms of democracy
but in the end his court-packing plan
didn't materialize
because two justices decided to side
with roosevelt and uphold the
constitutionality
of the social security act and the
national labor relations board
two key provisions of roosevelt's new
deal policy
with the court on his side roosevelt let
the court packing plan go
the change of heart by those justices
became known as
the switch in time that saved nine
meaning that
the permanence of the nine justice court
was preserved because
those justices had changed their minds
there have not been serious attempts at
reforming the supreme court since then
and personally i would not take very
seriously
any major reforms you may have heard
about
the institutions of the u.s government
are stable
and by design are very difficult to
change
like all of the political institutions
in the u.s the supreme court
has its flaws and its strengths yet
despite these
it has done a pretty good job at
maintaining its legitimacy
and reputation
[Music]
you